come on John so I am headed off to Miami
tomorrow morning at six a freakin
o'clock in the morning I'll be there
Miami I'll do a show first there's only
50 tickets left and we're not selling
them at the door so you have to buy them
online in the next 24 hours or you're
done and then the morning after that
concert I will be getting up really
early like 4:00 o'clock my time to go to
Haiti which reminds me because it is now
two days before my trip I need to go
take my malaria medication hopefully
this will not cause dizziness or nausea
or hallucinations like they say they
could cuz that would suck I got these
things at the travel doctor and she said
to me I have good news
the the malaria that they have in Haiti
is is the killer strain and of course
I'm like I agree with you that that is
news but barely that is a good thing
because the kind of malaria that kills
you is also the kind of malaria that
these always work against so that's good
so John a long long time ago you and I
went to the Dominican Republic and we
took a tour with a microfinance
organization and you can watch that
video it's deep in the archives
Brotherhood you point oh I will link to
it at the end of this video but the
thing about it is that the Dominican
Republic is like ten times better off
than Haiti but this is strange because
Haiti and the Dominican Republic are on
the same small island Hispaniola people
do of course have opinions thoughts
ideas about this that there are three
schools of thoughts first I'm going to
tell you about the one that is probably
the least obvious and that's the
environment let's pretend like this
camera battery is Hispaniola so one
third of it would be Haiti this third
over here and the rest of it would be
the Dominican Republic and then right
here on the border of the two is a giant
mountain range all of the warm wet air
hits and it lands in the Dominican
Republic and then it all falls before it
gets the top of the mountain so it falls
in the mountains and then it rolls right
back down off the edge of the dr so what
we have is a wet side and a dry side and
water is a very important ingredient for
making most things particularly for
agriculture also for other industries
this was all exacerbated by the second
thing which was colonialism Haiti was
pretty much france's biggest investment
in the Western Hemisphere they really
pushed it whereas the Dominican Republic
had about twenty thousand slaves Haiti a
third the size with less water had
300,000 the Dominican Republic was this
was owned by Spain by the way the
agricultural policies that they put in
place were really
exploited it ended in a lot of
deforestation which of course ends in
more runoff less soil and less water
retention all bad things for agriculture
Haiti shucked its colonialism a lot
sooner than most of the rest of the
world and while there was for some time
stability and Haiti this story of Haiti
in the twentieth century is one of the
third problem really really bad
government military coup civil war war
with the Dominican Republic military
occupation by the United States
dictators military rule every bad
government situation that you could
think of the longest period of stability
was under the Duvalier --zz very first
Francois and then his son jean-claude
who were as Shakespeare would say
gigantic partially-digested lumps aside
from their military forces killing
people for political reasons raping
people for fun they themselves took
foreign aid and all tax money and put it
in their pockets the Duvalier reign
finally ended in 1986 for the same
reason that all tyrannical dictatorships
and the people got too hungry since 1986
when the Duvalier reign ended there have
been attempts at democracy followed by
more military coos and at this point he
is still trying to figure out its
democratic process and of course as you
would expect the people of Haiti have
very little faith in that process it is
not a good situation and I dare you to
come up with a solution because no one
can but that of course does not mean
that we can't help people at least in
small ways and I'm excited to be a part
of that and hopefully allow you to help
as well in the future John I'll see you
on Wednesday
except that I won't because there's no
internet in Haiti so I'll see you
whenever I get back to the internet
goodbye I won't have time to make a
video on Friday so I filmed one
yesterday
it's about superhero superpowers and
John I'm gonna need you to upload that
video because clearly not a lot of
internet in Haiti